there is a silver lining there are
thousands and thousands millions of
people worldwide that are standing up to
this nonsense right now
the the draconian lockdowns the way they
have abused power that that western
democracies have become completely
illiberal has woken up the masses and
they make it very hard for us to see
right because cnn won't cover it and new
york times won't cover it or at least
they won't cover it in an honest way but
we've been talking about this canadian
trucker convoy for the last two weeks
where thousands and thousands
if not at this point millions of
canadians are standing up and saying no
more this [ __ ] trudeau we want to go
back to our lives you don't own us and
trudeau is just absolutely worse we'll
get to him in a second but the convoys
have been going all throughout canada
it's just been beautiful trudeau of
course said it was because these people
are transphobes which would mean that a
whole bunch of people got together and
because of their irrational fear of uh
of trans people they started protesting
throughout canada but it's spreading
okay it's spreading throughout the world
here is
australia
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
beautiful like absolutely beautiful and
guess what it's not going to be a super
spreader event and those people chose to
go and they love their country that's
what they're actually applauding for
right there absolutely beautiful despite
the insanity of what's going on over in
australia but it's spreading throughout
the world here's paris france
[Music]
hey
[Music]
i have no doubt that those people are
all over the political map some of them
are more conservative some of them are
more liberal these are people who just
want to live freely so we've got canada
we've got australia we've got france and
this just in the last two or three hours
from jerusalem israel
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
do you think that's because those crazy
jews have an irrational fear of trans
people or maybe it's because their own
government has forced them to be
injected four times and 87 boosters and
everything else uh now before
we get to the next portion of all of
this and then to my conclusion about
what we're going to do with these people
just a bit more of what's going on in
canada right now
[Applause]
[Applause]
do you guys see the through line here at
these protests they have the flags of
their nations because these people
realize that the people
are the rightful inheritors of the
nations not the politicians so those are
people with canadian flags chanting
freedom what you saw a moment ago was
was good decent australians with
australian flags talking about how much
they love their country and we've shown
you all the videos how instead of
burning down buildings and looting and
everything else which the mainstream
media told us was okay all over the
world during black lives matter and all
the rest of the nonsense of the last two
years
do you think that maybe that was because
they really wanted to just get rid of
trump and we haven't actually solved
racism but they don't need their foot
soldiers out there anymore so it's all
stopped in the last year because they've
got biden as the president you think
maybe there's something there
crazy i know um
these people are good people who love
their country and just want to live
freely and they're not bigots and
racists and everything else and i will
continue to stand with